[Music]  question has parallels to the many  worlds interpretation of quantum  mechanics stephen hawking and alan guth  envisioned our universe as just one of  countless island universes some with  constance very different than the  universal constants that we enjoy the  speed of light the strength of gravity  would be outliers and there'd be some  that have just the right goldilocks-like  properties to support life that could  later ask the question of why is our  universe so particularly finely tuned  to our existence to ask the question  that i just posed now colleague up at uh  uc berkeley raphael busso came up with  some ways to quantify the likelihood of  observable universes possessing  observers within them